[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara
halallweg Sonntagabend schön dass Sie
dabei sind wie auch Norbert Lehmann für
den Sport einen schön guten abendag von
mir schauen wir auf die
Nachrichtenthemen von heute
Überlebenskampf im Gazastreifen tausende
plündern hilfszentren in Israel Gerät
premier Netanyahu weiter unter
Druck Kämpferinnen gegen Klimawandel der
deutsche Umweltpreis geht an eine
klimaforscherin und an eine
holzbaunternehmerin und Duell der Rugby
Giganten Südafrika schlägt Neuseeland
knapp und ist nun
Rekordweltmeister im Kampf gegen die
Hamas schickt Israel noch mehr Bomben
und noch mehr Soldaten in den
Gazastreifen aufkosten der
Zivilbevölkerung die habe keinen
sicheren Zufluchtsort mehr sagt das
Internationale Rote Kreuz angemessene
humanitäre Hilfe seit derzeit nicht
möglich die israelische Armee hat die
Bewohner im Norden des gazaastreifens
erneut dazu aufgerufen in Richtung Süden
zu flüchten nahe der Stadt hanunes gebe
es eine
Sicherheitszone die Verzweiflung der
Menschen ist groß Pablo silalahi
berichtet die unis tausende Menschen
haben hier Zuflucht gesucht die
Lebensumstände in der eilig
eingerichteten Unterkunft katastrophal
erzählt Rami alakan der mit seiner Frau
und seinen sechs Kindern hier gestrandet
ist ich hoffe gott hat ein Erbarmen mit
uns und der Krieg endet bald wir haben
so viel gelitten wir halten das nicht
mehr aus was mit uns geschieht wir haben
inzwischen einen Zustand erreicht in dem
wir uns wünschen in den Trümmern
gestorben zu sein nur um ein bisschen
Ruhe zu haben unser Leben ist eine
Folter Zuflucht suchen viele auch in
Krankenhäusern das nutzt die Hamas nach
Angaben der israelischen Armee gezielt
aus unter gasas größter Klinik habe sie
ihre Kommandozentrale eingerichtet
missbrauche dort Hilfe suchende als
menschliche schutzschildde die Vereinten
Nationen sprechen vom Zusammenbruch der
zivilen Ordnung in Gaza aus Verzweiflung
plündern viele Menschen nach Angaben des
un Hilfswerks sind mehrere ihrer
Lagerhallen
betroffen die Angriffe auf Stellungen
der Terrororganisation hab was in Gaza
gehen indes weiter auch am Boden Rücken
israelische Truppen weiter in den
Gazastreifen vor diese Bilder hat die
Armee heute veröffentlicht
über Nacht haben wir die Zahl der
Einsatzkräfte im Gazastreifen erhöht und
sie haben sich den bereits dort
kämpfenden Kräften angeschlossen die
Einsätze am Boden und der Umfang der
Streitkräfte im Gazastreifen werden
schrittweise
ausgeweitet die Hamas setzt ihre
Terrorangriffe in Richtung Israel auch
heute weiter fort und sorgt dort für
eine weitere Nacht der
Angst von allen Seiten wird Israel
aufgefordert die humanitäre Lage der
Zivilisten im Gazastreifen zu verbessern
Michael bewerunge in telaviv wie
reagieren Regierung und Armee
darauf die Armee will offenbar mit dem
Fortschreiten der Bodenoffensive
weiteree humanitäre Zugeständnisse
machen heute wurde die zweite von drei
wasserleit aus Israel in den
Gazastreifen geöffnet mit Beginn der
Woche soll die Zahl der humanitären
Hilfslieferung in den gazerastreifen
massiv zunehmen die Telekommunikations
und Internetdienste wurden
wiederhergestellt also Israel versucht
einiges um einen humanitären Ausgleich
zu schaffen allerdings dürfte da auch
gewisser Druck aus den USA dahinter
stecken danke schön für den Moment wir
sprechen gleich noch mal denn in Israel
wächst der Druck auf Ministerpräsident
Netanyahu nicht nur wegen der Geiseln
viele geben ihm auch eine Mitschuld dass
die Hamas am 7 Oktober überhaupt so
wüten und morden konnte in Israel doch
Netanyahu weist im Gegensatz zu anderen
jegliche Verantwortung zurück l walpot
berichtet Benjamin netanahu gestern
Abend im Gespräch mit Angehörigen der
Geiseln er zeigt Verständnis für die
Sorgen der Familien er verspricht die
Freilassung haben nach wie vor oberste
Priorität wir werden alles tun um sie
nach Hause zu bringen auch nach dem
Einmarsch mit allem was uns zur
Verfügung
steht doch die Kritik wächst täglich
demonstrieren Familienangehörige in Tel
Aviv der Regierungschef unternehme zu
wenig für die Freilassung der Geiseln so
der
Vorwurf es wird viel geredet viele
Treffen mit den Familien aber derzeit
wird einfach nicht genug
unternommen
Netanyahu so arwöhnen immer mehr
Menschen in Israel sei vor allem damit
beschäftigt die Verantwortung für das
Versagen auf den Sicherheitsapparat
abzuwälzen zwar betonte der
Regierungschef gestern Abend vor der
Presse ich habe das schon einmal gesagt
ich wiederhole es noch einmal nach dem
Krieg werden wir alle aber alle
Antworten auf schwierige Fragen geben
müssen das schließt mich
ein aber in einem Tweet schob er nach
die Sicherheitsbehörden hätten das
Risiko eines Angriffs unterschätzt und
nicht ausreichend gewarnt es folgte ein
Sturm der Entrüstung Netanyahu musste
die Nachricht löschen und durch eine
Entschuldigung ersetzen er stehe voll
und ganz hinter allen Verantwortlichen
für die Sicherheit des Landes so
netanahus
Korrektur noch mal nach Tel Aviv Michael
wie angeschlagen ist
Netanyahu ziemlich angeschlagen er
kämpft um das nackte politische
Überleben
der Armeechef hat bereits Verantwortung
für das Versagen der Sicherheitskräfte
am 7 Oktober übernommen der
Geheimdienstchef der
Verteidigungsminister in der Reihe fehlt
nur noch der Premierminister aber wenn
er das täte dann müsste er wenn er
Verantwortung übernimmt am Ende dieses
kriegesens zurücktreten dann verlöre er
alles sein Amt sein Ansehen als der
vielleicht Premierminister als der er
sich sieht der immer die Sicherheit
garantiert hat von Israel und er würde
sich vielleicht am Ende als einfacher
Bürger Bibi in drei Gerichtsprozessen
die gegen laufen wiederfinden danke
schön für diese Einschätzung auch heute
wieder danke Michael
bewerunger und es gab heute auch noch
anderes der Bundeskanzler will Afrika
mehr Aufmerksamkeit widmen und ist jetzt
zum dritten Mal innerhalb seiner
Amtszeit dort am Nachmittag landete er
in Nigeria Deutschland will mit dem
bevölkerungsreichsten Land Afrikas
starker zusammenarbeiten vor allem im
Bereich Energie neben Öl soll das Land
künftig auch er Gas liefern morgen reist
Scholz weiter nach Ghana dort geht es
vor allem um
Migration die Türkei feiert Geburtstag
und ihr aktueller Präsident tut sich
schwer damit heute vor genau 100 Jahren
rief mustafha Kemal Atatürk die Republik
aus eine moderne Türkei als Nachfolgerin
des Osmanischen Reiches Atatürk setzte
die Trennung von Religion und Staat
durch plus eine stärkere Rolle der
Frauen ein schwieriges Erbe für
Präsident Erdogan JG Brase
berichtet am Abend hatte er den
stsschuss gegeben zum großen Feuerwerk
und Lichtshow auf dem Bosporus vorher
hatte Präsident Erdogan die Erfolge
seiner Regentschaft aufgelistet wie Atta
türkes damals gewollt habe sei die
Türkei auch heute Beschützer der
Benachteiligten meinte
Erdogan vom Balkan bis in den Kaukasus
von Asien bis Afrika Turkmenistan bis
Palästina wo immer Menschen unterdrückt
werden und in Not sind et ihn die Türkei
zu Hilfe und hält ihre
Hand unter seiner Herrschaft sei
Atatürks Demokratie gerettet worden
meinte Erdogan das aber sehen viele im
Land völlig anders zwar feierten sie den
100 Jahrestag doch in den Nationalstolz
mischten sich auch
Zweifel der türkischen Republik geht es
heute zwar ganz gut aber wie ist der
Zustand unserer Demokratie haben wir
wirklich eine funktionierende Demokratie
in der Türkei
die Einführung einer seäkularen
Demokratie war wohl die größte
Errungenschaft der neuen Republik die
mustafha Kemal Attatürk vor 100 Jahren
gründete die neue Verfassung gab Frauen
das Wahlrecht vor allem erklärte Atatürk
die strikte Trennung von Staat und
Religion heute versuche Erdogan die
Türkei wieder zu islamisieren sagen
seine Kritiker seine Unterstützer sehen
ihn als legitimen Nachfolger attatürks
so feierten die Menschen den 100
jahrestag ihres gespaltenen Landes heute
mit gemischten
Gefühlen seit dem 1 Mai gibt es das
deutschlandticket und es ist ein Erfolg
sagt der Verband der Verkehrsunternehmen
demnach hat sich die Zahl der Inhaber
bei rund 10 Millionen eingependelt
50% der Nutzer hatten zuvor schon ein
anderes Abo sind also Bestandskunden 40%
hatten Einzel oder zeitfahrkarten
gekauft und 8 bis 10% sind e
Neukunden trotz der zunehmenden
Bedrohungen dürfe der Kampf gegen den
Klimawandel nicht vom Platz ganz oben
auf der Prioritätenliste verdrängt
werden so der Appell des
Bundespräsidenten heute bei der
Verleihung des Deutschen umweltpreises
die 500.000 € Preisgeld gingen dieses
Jahr an zwei Frauen Clas
trumsen Verantwortung übernehmen das ist
das Motto der beiden diesjährigen
Trägerin des deutschen umweltpreises
Preisträgerin dagma Fritz Kramer schafft
dies nach Einschätzung der
Bundesstiftung Umwelt sogar im harten
Wettbewerb in der Bauwirtschaft ja wir
machen 40% des weltweiten co2s mit
unseren Baustoffen mit unserem Betrieb
der Gebäude und ich glaube da müssen wir
jetzt ran ihre Leidenschaft gehört im
Holz als Baustoff schon ihr Vater rüstet
den traditionsreichen Familienbetrieb
auf biologische Fertigung um sag mal
Fritz Kramer baut das konsequent aus mit
umweltfreundlich gewonnenem Holz aus der
Region oder neuen Ideen wie Verwertung
von holzspähen zur Isolation etwa für
ihr Engagement zum Thema Klimawandel
wurde die zweite Preisträgerin die
Forscherin Friederike Otto ausgezeichnet
sie beschäftigt sich mit einer neueren
Disziplin der
attributionswissenschaft welchen Anteil
hat der Klimawandel an extremen
Wetterereignissen eine Frage auf die sie
mit ihrem Team Antworten sucht mit ihrer
Forschung will sie aufrutteln eigentlich
ist es nicht so toll wenn jedes Jahr die
Wälder abbrennen
vielleicht es sich unser unser Leben und
unsere unsere Städte so zu ändern dass
das eben nicht immer wieder passiert
sinnvoll handeln und Verantwortung
übernehmen dazu soll der deutsche
Umweltpreis anregen er prägte als
Serienstar den Humor mehrerer
Generationen jetzt ist der ussauspieler
Matthew Perry mit 54 gestorben berühmt
wurde er mit der 90er Jahre Kultserie
friends in der Rolle des witzemachers
chendler die Serie über die New Yorker
Freunde bis heute ein Renner Perry
kämpfte Jahrzehnte lang gegen seine
Alkohol und Tablettensucht er wurde in
seinem Haus in Los Angeles tot
aufgefunden und jetzt zum Rugby ein
Traumfinale ein wmtaumfinale gestern
Abend in Paris Südafrika gegen
Neuseeland boah war das spannend ein
leidenschaftliches hart umkämpftes Duell
der Rugby Großmächte die Springboks
gegen die All Blacks am Ende gewinnt der
Titelverteidiger knapp mit 12 Z 11
Südafrika jetzt mit 4 WM erfolgen
Rekordweltmeister den Rhythmus vorgeben
das wollten die All Blacks aus
Neuseeland ihr hakeranz ein Ritual am
Ende aber setzte sich ein ungezügelter
Beat durch bis hinunter nach Kapstadt
die springbox aus Südafrika mit einer
aufopferungsvollen Abwehrleistung in
einem Giganten Duell das gerne noch mehr
dieser rassigen Spielszenen hätte bieten
können der ruhende Ball und dieser Mann
entschieden das Finale vier freeicks
durch
macht 12 Punkte die ganze Ausbeute aber
sie reichte Neuseelands vom Platz
gestellter Kapitän Sam Kane konnte von
draußen lediglich einen geglückten
Versuch seines Teams mit ansehen der
anschließende Kick hätte noch zwei
Punkte und damit den Sieg gebracht so
aber jubelt die springbox im
ausverkauften ST de France zu
Paris im ersten Sonntag Spiel der
Fußball buundesliga ein
höchstunterhaltsames 3:3 zwischen der
Eintracht und den BVB starke Frankfurter
legten vor Borussia zweimal mit dem
Ausgleich Dortmund bleibt vierter die
SGE 7 Weltcup Riesens schalom in Sölden
heute der Männer aber vom Winde verweht
wegen starker nicht nachlassender Böhen
wurde das Rennen erst verkürzt und dann
Mitte des ersten Durchgangs aus
sicherheitsgrüen abgebrochen gestern
hatten die Frauen ihren Wettbewerb noch
problemlos beenden
können und das war's auch schon Spar am
Sonntag danke schön der oktober zeigt
sich auch zu Beginn der neuen Woche sehr
mild vor allem in einem Streifen von der
Eifel bis nach Brandenburg viele Wolken
und Regen im Südosten bei Föhn Sonne 11
bis 20°
:4 Uhr begrüßt Sie Dunja Hayali im
heutejournal das gesamte heuteeteam sagt
Danke tschüss wünscht einen guten Start
in die neue Woche und empfiehlt jetzt
cha kunala berery mit Berlin direkt
vielen Dank Barbara auch wir schauen auf
den Krieg in N Ost und auf die Frage wie
gehen Deutschland und Europa damit um
darüber rede ich live mit dem deutschen
Verteidigungsminister dazu ein Blick auf
islamisch geprägte
demokratiefeindlichkeit und
Antisemitismus in Deutschland herzlich
willkommen bei Berlin direkt